good morning
today i'm proud to once again be
standing together with president
vanderline
as we announce a new uh groundbreaking
initiative between the european union
and the united states
first
we're coming together to reduce europe
dependence on russian energy
putin has issued russia's energy
resources to coerce
and manipulate its neighbors that's how
he's used it he's used the profits to
drive his war machine
that's why earlier this month i
announced the united states would ban
all imports of russian energy to make it
clear the american people would not be
part of subsidizing putin's brutal
unjustified war against people ukraine
at the time
i noted that
we were able to take this steps when
others could not because the united
states is a net exporter of energy with
a strong domestic industry
and the united states welcomed the
european union's powerful statement
earlier this month committing to rapidly
reduce its dependence on russian gas
today we've agreed on a joint game plan
toward that goal
while accelerating our progress toward a
secure clean energy future
this initiative focuses on two core
issues one
helping europe reduces dependency on
russian gas as quickly as possible
secondly
reducing europe's demand for gas overall
to address the first point the united
states together with our international
partners
they're we're going to work to ensure an
additional
1 15 1 5 15 billion cubic meters of
liquefied natural gas lng for europe
this year
and as the euro as the eu works to
discontinue it buying russian gas well
before 2030 it will also also work to uh
ensure additional eu market demand for
50 billion cubic meters of lng from the
united states annually by 2030.
to accomplish this the european
commission is going to work with the
member states to store gas across the
continent
to build more infrastructure to receive
lng
and to take steps to increase the
efficiency of gas
this build-out this build-up will occur
in a way that consists is consistent
with not in conflict with the zero net
zero climate goal we should with that
we're shooting for
it's going to take some time to adjust
gas supply chains and infrastructure
that has built
the last decade before for the last
decade so we're going to have to make
sure that families in europe
can get through this winter and the next
while we're building an infrastructure
for a diversified resilient and clean
energy future
at the same time
this crisis also presents an opportunity
it's a catalyst a catalyst that will
drive the investments we need to double
down on our clean energy goals and
accelerate progress toward our net zero
emissions future
that's what the second part of this
initiative is all about
the united states and the european union
are going to work together to take
concrete measures to reduce dependence
on natural gas period
and to maximize the available develop
the availability and use of renewable
energy we're going to accelerate
widespread adoption of energy efficient
technologies and equipment like smart
thermostats
the work then work to uh
work to electrify heating systems all
across europe
we're going to invest in innovative
solutions and technologies to make the
switch from fossil fuels
and together we'll advance the use of
clean and renewable hydrogen to reduce
our carbon emissions
this these steps will increase energy
security
economic security and national security
and we're going to stand up a joint task
force to implement these changes and
drive progress
that will be co-chaired by
representatives from the white house and
the president of the european union's
team the
commission's team
madam president i know i know that
eliminating russian gas will have costs
for europe
but it's not only the right thing to do
from a moral standpoint
it's going to put us on a much stronger
strategic footing
and i'm proud to announce that we've
also reached another major breakthrough
in transatlantic data flows
privacy and security are key elements of
my digital agenda
and today
we've agreed to unprecedented
protections for data privacy and
security for our citizens
this new arrangement will enhance the
privacy shield framework
promote growth and innovation in europe
and the united states and help companies
both small and large compete in the
digital economy
just as we did when we resolved the
boeing airbus dispute
and lifted the steel aluminum tariffs
the united states and the eu are finding
creative new approaches to knit our
economies and our people closer together
grounded on shared values
this framework
underscores our shared commitment to
privacy
to data protection and to the rule of
law
and it's going to allow the european
commission to once again authorize
transatlantic data flows that help
facilitate 7.1 trillion dollars in
economic relationships with the eu
so thank you again madam president
for your personal friendship for your
partnership and above all your
leadership
all of this is bringing the european
union united states even closer together
and that's a win for all of us
so i thank you all and i'm now going to
yield podium
president let me pull this out
my shower here
is it out enough there you go
thank you
thank you
mr president dear joe
your presence here in brussels this week
at the nato summit
at the g7 and at our european council
sends a very powerful message to the
world
the transatlantic partnership stands
stronger and more united than ever
and we are determined to stand up
against russia's brutal war
this war will be a strategic failure for
putin
our cooperation on the four successive
waves of sanctions against russia has
been extraordinary and exceptional
the sanctions are now working their way
deep into the russian system draining
putin's resources to finance this
atrocious war
our work on sanctions also shows
that when we act together we're stronger
and we really can make a difference
and we are continuing to reinforce our
cooperation in many strategic ways
on humanitarian and security assistance
to ukraine
on energy
on fighting the threats against our
democracies
on solving outstanding issues in the eu
us cooperation including in data
production protection and privacy
in a world faced with disorder our
transatlantic unity upholds fundamental
values and rules that our citizens
believe in
let me focus first on refugees
until now around three and a half
million people have left ukraine
half of them children every second
refugee is a child
and the numbers will keep rising
so together we are mobilizing massive
resources
to support those displaced by the
conflict be it in ukraine or in the
neighboring countries
just this week for example i announced
that the european union will allocate an
extra 3.4 billion euros for this purpose
and more will come
this demonstrates our deep support for
ukraine and its citizens
and i want to tell the american people
how grateful europe is for their
unwavering support
this support also extends to
strengthening europe's energy security
and independence from russian fossil
fuels
as you know we aim to reduce this
dependency on russian fossil fuels and
to get rid of it
and this can only be achieved
through of course first of all
investment in renewables
but also through additional gas supplies
including lng deliveries
so we want as europeans to diversify
away from russia
towards suppliers that we trust that our
friends and that are reliable
and therefore the u.s commitment
to provide the european union with
additional at least 15 billion cubic
meters of lng this year
is a big step in this direction
because this will replace the lng supply
we currently
receive from russia
and looking ahead
the united states and europe will ensure
stable demand and supply
for additional at least 50 billion cubic
meter of u.s lng
until 2030
and if we look at that
this amount 50 bcm per year
is replacing one third already
of the russian gas
going to europe today
so we are right in on track now to
diversify away from russian gas and
towards our friends and partners
reliable and trustworthy suppliers
we need to secure our supplies not just
for next winter but also for the years
ahead and this is a an important a big
starting point to do that
our partnership aims to sustain us
through this war
to work on our independence from russian
fossil fuels
but it also focuses on building a
greener future with climate neutrality
we will work together also with our
energy intensive industry
and the good news is
that the infrastructure that we use for
gas today
can be used for clean hydrogen in the
future
so this investment we are doing right
now
is also an investment in the
decarbonizing of our economy
the corporation shows the power of our
democracies
i particularly welcome that we will step
up our respective action on
strengthening democracies the rule of
law
the freedom of media in the world
and we also need to continue adapting
our own democracies to a changing world
this is particularly true when it comes
to digitalization
in which the protection of personal data
and privacy has become so crucial
therefore i'm very pleased
that we have found an agreement in
principle
on a new framework for transatlantic
data flows
this will enable predictable and
trustworthy data flows between the eu
and u.s
safeguarding privacy and civil liberties
and i really want to thank commissioner
reinders and secretary raimondo for
their tireless efforts over the past
month
to finish a balanced and effective
solution
this is another step in our
strengthening our partnership
we managed to balance security and the
right
[Music]
you